is Kendall Jenner's starting a new trend  the reality star stepped out in West  Hollywood on Thursday rocking an edgy  ensemble we've never seen done before  Kendall took her street style to a whole  new level sporting an oversized rips  Metallica t-shirt sexy bralette and body  chain paired with classic denim jeans  and white booties we are obsessed with  this bold fashion statement from the 20  year old supermodel they love it  it's clear from her snapchat post even  Kendall thought she nailed the casual  look  she used the 100 emoji on-screen the  model has been wowing us recently on  Tuesday Kendall instagrammed a cheeky  outtake from her September vogue photo  shoot she flaunted her toned tush in a  black one-piece swimsuit and looked  incredible safe to say Kendall is style  goals